somewhere deep inside you know what kind
of person you were designed to be if you
want to produce great acorns
think like an oak not like an acorn
think like the person you intend to
become like the Christian question what
would Jesus do ask yourself how would
the person I'd like to be do the things
I'm about to do the Acorn has three
parts it's got a stem a cap and a seed
and the stem represents its connection
to the past all the acorns all the Oaks
that have ever existed in its line
before are encoded in that transfer
through that stem the legacy into this
acorn the cap holds onto the seed until
the seeds ready to grow on its own so
the cap represents your coaches your
mentors your your role models your guide
your parents your friends your teachers
and when you're ready to grow on your
own the seed of that acorn holds not
only your potential but the potential of
every future generation of acorns that
will spring from that line so let me ask
a question what kind of seed is in you
see I believe part of our responsibility
in life is to find out who we are to
discover ourselves first off we need to
respect our nature we need to realize we
are part of a continuing chain that
carries a legacy and a responsibility
and if that's the case then we need to
recognize that we were not biological
coincidences we were in I believe
there's a creator creator and I believe
you were intentionally created for a
myriad of purposes there are many things
we can do with our lives and I think
it's our job to find out what those
things are and to do them as well
as we possibly can so that we're passing
along the right imprint for the next
generation and that's just simply my
life philosophy that's the way I look at
it so first we need to respect our
nature second we need to know our nature
take care of STARTTLS advice know
thyself but know things about yourself
that most people don't discover for
example know how you're smart not just
how smart you are in comparison to
others in what ways are you smart know
what you care about what are the values
that motivate your choices know what
your personal velocity is the intensity
and drive with which you naturally
operate know the background imprint
positive neutral or negative that you
carry with you and what effect its had
on you know your behavioral style how
you come across to other people know
your the patterns and your choices so
that you're continually learning more
and more about what it's like to be you
so you can do an even better job of it
and then we need to apply our nature we
need to nurture our nature by expressing
ourselves in the world say I never
expected to be anything but ordinary I
was raised to be nice and ordinary I
expected I would grow up to be like dad
work for the phone company I figured I'd
go to work for the phone company maybe
work in an office I figured I'd live
you know I'd work till 65 I'd have 1.3 4
kids I'd retire at 65 and then I died at
the statistical average age for my you
know my gene pool that's what I expected
until one day in 1972 on the radio in
the next room to mine I heard a voice
that changed everything I was working
for the Little Rock Housing Authority
Little Rock Arkansas urban renewal
agency I was a government clerk making
five hundred and twenty five dollars a
month I weighed 200 pounds this is 148 I
smoked two packs of cigarettes a day I
had never set a goal in my life I didn't
have a college degree and no money in
the bank I was newly married with a new
baby at home and I didn't expect much
from life and in the next room I heard
the voice of Earl Nightingale
own at the time as the Dean of personal
motivation he was on 900 radio stations
around the world and what he said that
day will forever resonate with me he
said if you will spend one extra hour
each day studying your chosen field
you'll be a national expert in that
field in five years or less that hit me
like a tornado it rearranged everything
in my life it I started doing the math
and our extra a day let's say five days
a week 50 weeks a year that's 1,250
hours over five years if I spent me just
ordinary me 1,250 hours studying one
subject Wow yeah I could actually be a
national expert what I want to be an
expert at that's not Urban Renewal
and then it occurred to me a few weeks
later I want to do what the guy on the
radio is doing but I had no idea what
that was I just knew it felt right to
get into the field of human development
I thought will see an hour a day I'm a
government clerk I've got eight hours a
day I could do this by Thursday and then
I started thinking about what he had
said and I took him seriously an hour a
day
I focused well I would thought I was
kind of behind the game so I needed two
hours and three and fourth button so I
overcompensated
and I became fanatical about the field
of human development and in that five
year period I went from being a
government clerk with very little
aspiration to being a full-time speaker
and trainer in two years that was 1972
in 1974 I've started buying Earl
Nightingale training materials and
selling them to businesses by 1984 his
company was selling my training
materials worldwide they sold three and
a half million dollars worth of one of
my first audio albums in the first two
years it was out I was blown away his
formula works and I've seen it work for
hundreds and even thousands of people in
the many many years since that time that
I've been sharing that message
think about that if you were to focus
one that will you hear Ted audience if
you were to focus a half an hour a day
extra just beyond the TED talk that you
always watch right every day okay beyond
that if you were to focus half an hour
of study on one field of endeavor for
five consecutive years you'd not only
transform you you transform the world
around you and we collectively would
transform the world as we know it today
you and I were born with the gift to
make this a better place even if we
didn't improve we could make the world
better right now we could encourage
people compliment people we could solve
problems we could pick up trash we could
fix things we could bring new ideas but
as you grow you become a bigger source
for the rest of life to express itself
through you you were put here for a
reason it's contained in that acorn so
nurture your nature figure out first off
I am valuable except that I want to know
who I am and I want to know how I
operate and how can I understand me
better and then I want to nurture that
nature I want to apply myself in the
world and put myself to work in such
ways that the rest of the world says
well that's cool if he or she can do it
I could probably do it I wonder how they
did it and then we start spreading that
and the ripple goes worldwide so ask
yourself every day how would the person
I'd like to be do the things I'm about
to do
you